let's jump into this first story we got
this from the post millennial John
fetterman co-sponsor Senate Bill despite
being institutionalized since February
15th Letterman's office has not said who
is co-sponsoring legislation with his
name on it while he remains
institutionalized a senior aide revealed
that fetterman would be hospitalized for
up to two months so it's clearly not him
I guess that's the important point is
they're saying he's co-sponsoring this
bill but it's probably just a member of
his staff and uh I got to show you this
right here from Twitter
or from John cardillo on Twitter he says
this is from February 25th it was a
while ago being told that fetterman is
essentially brain uh brain dead
and and uh let me let's start over being
told that fetamine is essentially brain
dead and it's being hidden because
keeping it in him in office until August
18th avoids a special election which
Republicans would most certainly win
this must be investigated